foreign
is moving on and moving out of her
Bel-Air estate and for a hefty payday it
just happens that way it's a funny thing
like E.T has learned the singer listed
her family home for 42.5 million dollars
just a few months after tying the knot
with Ben Affleck home is about where the
people you love are it doesn't matter
what you know place you are it doesn't
where you are in the world so what does
JLo's luxurious multi-million dollar
mansion offer
foreign
the property is described as a rare and
extraordinary home located on eight
awe-inspiring acres of land
check out the main level living room
with Sky High ceilings there's also a
30-seat screening room zoom in closely
and you can see JLo and Ben's movie
posters on the wall are you with me
then we have the game room with a very
familiar sign
foreign
but it's the outdoor area that has
caught our attention
[Music]
yeah there's a 100-seat Amphitheater and
an infinity pool but the coolest part
has to be the private lake with a Sandy
Beach and did we mention the massive
estate also includes private hiking
trails it was worth it and if the pad
looks familiar it's probably because you
saw it when Jen filmed her 73 questions
segment with Vogue which of your
characters are you most similar to
um I think there's a little bit of me in
all the characters I play but I would
have to say Selena yep that's the triple
threat in her kitchen and her incredible
backyard ballater dance track depends on
my mood but dance track so with Jen's
crib up for grabs seems like she and her
hubby Ben are ready to plant roots in a
new home following their two weddings
baby I'm a shelter
shelter from a broken Paradise the
lovebirds first tied the nod in a
last-minute ceremony in Vegas last July
and so I was just like what's is this
happening is this really happening and
we were so happy and of course it was
happening but I just felt like the
wedding was so stressful and one day Ben
just says
okay let's just go to Vegas and get
married tonight and I was like
it was that day
what can I tell you we're just having a
good time then in August the two had a
magical Georgia wedding at Ben's
sprawling estate what's the best part of
this chapter and being married to Ben
there's so many things I mean I I
couldn't you don't have enough time
right now let me tell you about my
relationship with Beth
he's a beautiful man he's dreaming
[Music]